Egypt has declared seven days of
national mourning in response to the
deaths of these Egyptian Coptic
Christians can you give us your reaction
to those deaths were actually is the
exact reaction of every Egyptian was
shocked by this barbaric crime committed
against innocent Egyptian trying to earn
a living in Libya so which saddened
shocked but we believe that with that
this is part of a whole phenomena will
be facing in Egypt and throughout the
Arab world in the last few years we need
to pull our force together and face this
threat that is coming closer to home and
by home I mean not only Egypt but I mean
also Europe well yes and as part of that
Egypt has carried out these bombing
raids in Libya what details can you give
of that military operation actually I
don't have a full details their report
we know that egyptian war plane has
bombarded the southern lydia libya in
the city of donna which is actually
under the control of the ash or idle we
have been able to destroy some of their
arm depot a communication center and
some reports are pointing to the death
of 50 of their fighters this is what I
have in terms of Egypt reaction so far
and is this a one-off action by Egypt or
do you see this as part of a longer term
involvement by Egypt and the coalition's
fight against Islamic state and Islamic
state sympathizers well Egypt is a firm
member of the coalition against ISIL
we've been fighting ISIL in Egypt in
northern Sinai and now we've been for we
are fighting them in Libya so as far as
Egypt commitment
it has been there it will remain and
will continue in the future the problem
is that we and you and everyone has
failed so far to snuff this organization
out we need really to act together and I
think what happened yesterday is a
demonstration that it's what's happening
in Syria and Iraq is now moving to Libya
Libya where the Egyptian airplane struck
was at 300 kilometers away from Italian
coastline so can we expect to see more
airstrikes by Egypt in the days ahead I
do not have information about what are
our future plan but I know very well
that Egypt is resolved to deal with the
threat will take any necessary measures
to deal with it we are also in the same
process helping the legitimate Libyan
government and its elected parliament to
face the danger and the threat of ISIL
and other extremist group in Libya so
we've been actively involved before this
crime and would remain in the future
well yes how much coordination has there
been with Libya I ask this because one
of Libya's parliaments based in Tripoli
has called these airstrikes and assault
on its sovereignty one of Libya's
Parliament because the in Libya there is
only one Parliament that has been
elected and the whole international
community including the UK has
recognized this Parliament as the
legitimate Parliament of Libya and with
with with this one and its government
Egypt is in close coordination on daily
base and actually they were informed
about our intention before we went ahead
and bombarded and finally these attacks
as we say taken place in Libya how
concerned are you about Egypt and
Islamic state influence there there is
no Islamic state in Egypt per se that is
Islamic state of course in a very
confined area in northern Sinai in 600
kilometers from Cairo we're dealing with
that
we're dealing quite effectively with
that and now we have what's happening in
Libya we are concerned that the
international community is not doing
what it should be doing it is about at
this time that we all act together the
Security Council has to take stock of
what happened we are fighting in Egypt
and the Arab world for our identity
against an organization that is against
humanity in large say in a sense so I
think the the horrible picture we saw
yesterday is a call for Egypt and the
Arab world and Europe and the
international community to come together
unite and fight this organisation NASA
camelle Egypt's ambassador to the UK
thank you for your time this afternoon
we appreciated